if you're looking to grow your business
around the world by bringing on
international distributors I'm going to
share with you my five-step plan for how
to accomplish that hi I'm Evan
Carmichael
I believe in entrepreneurs and I
recently got a question from one of my
youtube viewers love you guys Adnan who
wrote in to say hey Evan I just started
watching your videos and I'm amazed
wonderful work Thank You Adnan I had a
question though I would like to know how
do you get in contact with international
agents like I live in a country where
readymade garments are the cheapest to
produce I'm looking for an agent who
could help me distribute and develop
countries like America where can I find
such contacts love this question Adnan
and as a quick little background on what
I've gone through my first business was
a software company I was based in
Toronto Canada and was struggling to get
sales and one of the things that really
helped me was negotiating deals with
international agents who could represent
our product it helped me go from making
$300 to get in my first five figure
check and then eventually being able to
sell in over 30 different countries so
here's the five-step process that I went
through that you can use to grow your
business number one is research
companies research is super easy to do
and you should be out there online
looking Google look on YouTube look on
social media for people who are
potential distributors for you an ideal
fit should be somebody who's already
selling different types of products to
your target market so when I was out
trying to find distributors from my
scientific software I was trying to find
people who are already selling to
scientists because that was the market I
wanted to reach I didn't want to find
somebody who lived in the country I
wanted to get into but had no experience
in the area and tried to convince them
to try to sell my scientific software
instead I looked for the companies who
already were selling to them and had
complementary products and services but
weren't direct competitors so start by
making that list of companies who's
already selling complementary products
and services to what you have to offer
and we'd see adding your product as a
value add to put through their chain
number two is create a deck
want to create an overview of your
company to show how reputable you are
there's a big fear in dealing with new
companies that maybe you're going to
fold after a couple of months maybe
you're going to take my money and run
that you're not going to stick around so
you want to show that you have
credibility and authority you want to
make sure you have a website that looks
legitimate and you create a PowerPoint
file or PDF that you can send them
showing as much credibility as possible
show how long you've been around for
show how many customers you have show
what media you've been in any anything
that you can share that makes me feel
like it's a safe bet going with you
instead of just gambling on some new
startup don't you show them the
opportunity that they have working with
you reduce their risk by showing the
credibility that you have any time
somebody's evaluating proposal they're
going to look at risk and then a look at
reward and too many times entrepreneurs
focus only on bumping up that reward but
if there's high risk the person is going
to say no so you have to increase the
reward and reduce the risk as much as
possible so create an amazing deck
number three is reach out with momentum
so you've made your list of all the
people you want to get in touch with you
created an amazing website and an
amazing deck to wow them now you want to
reach out to them introduce yourself but
have momentum behind you you don't want
to look desperate you don't want to make
it look like you're you're struggling
and this is your last chance at becoming
successful the way I reached out with
momentum to my potential distributors
was finding companies who already were
interested in our product that lived in
their country so when I approached the
potential distributor agent in Japan I
would show them all the results we
already had from Japan I would show them
that people were visiting our website
from Japan the people were downloading
the free demo of our product from Japan
that we had some customers from Japan
and I would say hey we have all this
opportunity coming from the Japanese
market and we don't know what to do with
it we'd love to partner with a local
expert who can really take this and run
so if you don't have customers yet then
show inquiries or show leads if you
don't have leads yet then show web
traffic if you don't have web traffic
from that country then go and get some
web traffic from that country you got to
show that you have some
momentum there so that you're reaching
out from a position of strength and not
despair and weakness number four is
discuss terms once you get in a call
with them and they learn about your
business they're going to want to know
what kind of terms are they going to get
how much is it going to cost them
what kind of commissions are they going
to get from it are you going to be
funneling them leads or not I'm going to
share with you three of the key terms
that I look for in every single
agreement that I made the first was
having an opt-out clause which meant
that within 30 days if I wasn't happy
with what they were doing I could cancel
on them and not owe them any more money
the second was a jurisdiction which
means if there's ever a conflict as if
there's ever a disagreement if there's
ever an opportunity that you might go to
court you're always governed by your
local laws so it always be governed
under the laws of Ontario Canada where I
was from and if we had to fight them
they would have to come to our courts to
fight us and number three is exclusivity
which meant they were the only ones to
potentially represent us in their
country if you deal with non-exclusive
then I would give them between 25 and 30
percent commission for every product
they sold for us but it also let me
negotiate with other people in their
country where if it was exclusive I
would give them 40 percent of every sale
that we made and it would be the only
person that would be allowed to sell in
their country
we'd also funnel them lead so that if we
got somebody from our website asking us
from their market then I would send them
the lead instead of trying to close them
myself and in general made a whole lot
of sense having people local on the
ground because I don't understand the
Japanese market I don't understand the
Japanese language I don't want to wake
up in the middle of the night to be able
to talk to a Japanese customer I'd much
rather have somebody local take care of
that for me
we also required our exclusive
distributors to purchase prepaid
inventory in advance so the first deal I
made was for 13 and a half thousand
dollars with a distributor in the UK it
was an exclusive arrangement where they
would take 40 percent commission on
everything sold and nobody else
represent us in the UK market and they
pre purchased thirteen and a half
thousand dollars worth of our software
that we would the dark as they started
making sales so know what terms you
in advance of going into that meeting
with them number five start a trial it
takes time for a company to get to know
your products and services and be able
to represent you really well it also
takes time for you to train them and
educate them and work with them on the
process so they can really represent you
that the best that they can in their
market so start with a three-month trial
train them work with them funnel them
leads if that's part of your deal make
sure that they understand who you are
what you're all about and are doing
their best possible job to represent you
you'll find quickly that some people are
really dedicated really motivated and
are moving a lot of product for you and
others you'll find talker with a good
game but then don't actually deliver any
results so keep the ones that are doing
well up to the trial and fire the ones
who art so that's my five-step process
to getting international distributors
that work for me I had a lot of success
with it and I hope that it works for you
as well believe for those of you
watching like the video you want to see
more like it
you can subscribe to the channel and let
me know what you think if you have a
question in the comments below thank you
so much for watching and I'll see you
soon self-improvement books are like
Fitness books they never work on their
own what you need is a trainer that's
Evan gap the newsletter
you